What notes do you give screenwriters the
most
[Music]
let's see there's so many
um I give some of the same notes so much
that I have I now have a template of
notes right so that you know back in the
day I used to have to rewrite the same
note over and over and over but now I
kind of have a template of
uh some of the notices I give the most
often but I think the largest one is
lack of a goal or a problem to solve
and lack of an inciting incident because
the inciting incident causes the goal or
the problem to solve so usually if there
is no goal or no problem it's because
there was nothing that caused it and so
I end up giving those two things or I'll
say your inciting incident is very clear
this is what it is and anytime I do it I
follow it up with this is what it is
that way the writer can go that's not
what it is and they can realize oh well
it's not as clear as you thought it was
right
um but just because you have a clear
inciting incident doesn't mean you now
have a clear goal or a clear problem and
so that's the nuts and bolts of what
your screenplay is so if your inciting
incident isn't clear and if the goal
that they're trying to achieve or
problem they're trying to solve isn't
clear then now I'm going to be lost in
the sauce of the rest of your screenplay
because I don't know what I'm tracking
so kind of like an essay right right you
have your um the first page of your of
your essay you have to have your thesis
statement usually in your first
paragraph because the thesis statement
is telling us this is what my hypothesis
is this is what I'm going to try to
prove to you and then all of the the
following paragraphs have the evidence
of the thing that you hypothesized or
the thing that you're trying to prove so
now I can read it and go okay this
connects back to that this connects back
to that because I know what I'm tracking
the same thing is true in a screenplay
if you haven't given me that inciting
incident and that goal or that problem
then I don't have a thesis statement so
I don't know what I'm looking for so you
can have a whole lot of Adventure a
whole lot of fun a whole lot of action a
whole lot of whatever but what does it
all mean if I don't know what I'm
supposed to be tracking if I don't know
if this is even if if their story should
even be taking them down that path
because you didn't make it very clear
for me what they were seeking in the
first place
how many tries does it take for most New
Riders then to once you give them those
notes correct it several drafts yes but
I think it depends on the person
um some people are great at revising at
addressing notes right
um that's another skill set that writers
need to have and
um not all writers have it just because
you are revising doesn't mean you're
solving the problem
just because you're changing your script
and writing another draft does not mean
that you're fixing what the issue was
right so a you have to get a note
that informs you of what the issue is
right so um we were kind of talking
about development Executives earlier
right and most development executives
are not writers it's not an expectation
for them to be writers and there isn't a
training program in story you know for
them to be Executives like we talked
about they're coming in with their
Rolodex of who they know their job is to
connect people to each other their job
is branding and marketing and all these
things and they're also giving you notes
on your on your drafts but they might
not necessarily know the same language
that you know as a writer because they
didn't study screenwriting right so
sometimes writers can be given a note
that they simply just don't understand
because they're not speaking the same
language as the person who's giving the
note so it's harder for me to then say
well that person doesn't know how to
address notes when the note itself might
have been the problem right if the note
is saying hey we have a problem here but
it can't tell the writer why there's a
problem then the writer is left to not
only figure out the why but also then
figure throughout the how to fix it
right and so if they don't know what the
actual problem is then they're not going
to be able to address it and Executives
um uh usually try to solve the problem
for writers and I spend a lot of my time
when I'm doing my training with
Executives I train them in story because
I know again most of them are not
writers they didn't go to film school
they don't have to go to film school
there's no training in that so I will
work with Executives so they can learn
the ACT structure for whatever it is
their brand is doing try to teach them
the jargon so that they can more
effectively communicate with their
writers right but let's say they don't
have that information so Executives
spend a lot of their times going well
what if we did this or what if we did
that but again if you don't know story
structure then your what if might be
exacerbating the problem right and now
the writer has been given examples of
what they can do and they may think the
executive is telling me that's what I
have to do and so then they put into the
script with the executive suggested and
the problem is still there but neither
of them knows why the problem is still
there because maybe neither of them know
structure very well you know what I mean
so if the note is clear
and then the writer can't address it
then it might be that they just aren't
very good at addressing notes they might
be great at giving you a good first
draft second draft a good foundation
right but when it comes to really making
things clear that just might not be
their skill set there are other writers
who are great at that who are not going
to do the first draft they're not going
to do the second draft they're going to
be able to come in and they're going to
address those notes right and so I've
dealt with some new writers who after
one or two times but talking to me
they're able to address notes right but
that's also because I'm speaking their
language I'm talking to them in the
language that they speak about writing
and then I have other clients where they
can talk to me 10 times and they still
won't be able to address the note but
that's just because they don't have the
skill set to address the note it's a
totally different skill and it's
something that I'm gonna figure out how
to teach so I've been giving uh more
kind of uh workshops and talks on how to
address notes because if you want to be
a professional writer and you want to
not be Rewritten all the time and you
want to be able to stay with your
project from the beginning to the end
you have to be able to address notes and
I just think we don't talk about that
often enough
what if they understand story and you're
speaking their language but they feel
that their version is right yeah so this
is where you hope that there is an
opportunity for open dialogue right on
one side of it it doesn't matter if you
think it's right now that it's been
purchased by the studio or network it's
theirs not yours so it doesn't matter
that you think it's right you know what
I mean they could be giving you a note
because it's coming from the very top
and this is what it has to be you don't
have to like it your job is to do it
because at this point they're paying you
for it that's literally your job
now with that being said
depending upon like we said earlier you
got to read the room understand the
environment know if this is one of those
cases where it's like you know what let
me just address the note or if it's
maybe I can talk to them about it then I
would say the same thing needs to be
true you as a writer need to understand
how to express yourself well enough to
make them understand why you're right
and it's not by saying I'm right you
have to be able to show them in the
script if we make this change it's going
to have this ripple effect which is
going to cause this is that what you
would like the executive who probably
didn't understand you know may not have
understand understood the note that they
were giving was going to make those
changes might go Oh No actually that's
not what I want at all but you wouldn't
have known if you didn't ask and it's
about how you ask right versus no we're
not going to change that it's blah blah
blah but being able to explain to them
well for example if um the executive
says I don't like this moment where the
daughter curses her mom out I don't like
that at all and they decide to change it
to the daughter coming in and saying
something nice right that changes
everything
because if I say something negative to
someone we're going to take that
negative tension into the next scene if
I come in and I say something positive
to someone we're going to take that
positive tension into the next thing
right and if the point was the daughter
curses out the mother in this scene
because eventually they're going to get
into an actual fist fight if I change
this and make it positive how do we get
them there
so then the question becomes do you not
want them to have a negative
relationship do you not want them to get
to this fight because the writer is
going to be thinking I still got to get
them there and will it now feel
disingenuous if this moment is gone how
do we now show the trajectory of them
going from one end of the extreme to the
other right whereas what the executive
was really just trying to say is I
didn't like the word choice
in how she was talking to her mother I
still want it to be negative I just
don't want her to curse but if they
can't be that specific then now the
writer is going oh they don't want any
negativity at all and now we got to
change everything and blah blah blah but
being able to have that conversation is
going to be helpful and it's another
thing that I tell
you know Executives about the notes
process right like a lot of places and
everybody does it differently because
like we say you got to read the room you
gotta know what it is everybody does it
differently but a lot of places will
give the notes in the moment to the
writer so the executives have gotten
together hopefully with the studio as
well maybe they did maybe they didn't
and they will get their notes together
then they'll get on the phone with the
with the writer and they'll read out the
notes or discuss the notes with the
writer now the writer has received all
of this what is considered negative
information because we're sensitive
right so even even if they said one time
really good job but the rest of it was
change change change change change
change change change all we're hearing
is bad bad I'm a bad person I'm a bad
person then at the end of the phone call
they'll go okay do you got it you good
and the writer is gonna lie and go yeah
yeah everything's good and then they get
off the phone and now they're freaking
out right whereas if you're able to send
those notes a day or two a day or two
ahead of time then the writer has an
opportunity to cry scream whatever it is
going to do digest the notes and and
then have questions prepared for things
that they don't understand but we
usually don't get to get to the question
part because we spent the whole notes
call you know reading out the notes well
they're writers they know how to read
they can read the notes they don't need
you to read them to them what what they
need is a discussion what they need is
to be able to say so when you said you
don't want the cursing did you mean you
don't want a negative relationship or
did you just mean that you want her to
use different words now the writer has
had time to digest and come back and ask
the question and now the executive can
go oh yeah yeah it's just about the
words right but you have to have you
have to have time in those calls to be
able to do that and you usually don't if
you're spending the entire call giving
the notes instead of being able to
actually discuss them so that the writer
feels good about what they understand
you're asking them for which gets you
closer to them actually being able to
address the note then if they can't
address the note now you might be able
to say oh this writer doesn't address no
as well
so should should a writer maybe uh and I
don't know if this is overstepping their
bounds but ask hey is there any way I
could just get the notes and email to me
first and then we can do the call so
then they can compose themselves and be
just in a better frame of mind yes they
can ask and they can also say no
right but I think I think you can ask if
you know that it's better for your
process and really I think it's probably
better for most people's process right
like you don't want to be on the spot
because also depending upon what your
relationship is with these Executives or
what their expectations are they want
you to pitch out your solves right then
so they're on the phone going this
doesn't work this doesn't work this
doesn't work okay so what are your ideas
and all you're thinking is I'm just now
taking in the fact that it doesn't work
I don't have an idea yet I don't know
how to fix it yet I need to go think
about it but now you're on the spot and
you're trying to come up with these
answers right whereas if you had the 48
Hours like I'll even say don't send it
you don't want to send it out a week
before because you don't want a writer
sitting in it right because in our
sensitivity we will then try to address
all those notes ourselves and then come
back and go well we fixed it all right
it's like no we still need to talk about
it to make sure we're on the same page
right
um but I do think if you if you can give
that writer 48 hours to read it digest
it and come with their questions then
that's helpful some people just don't do
it that way because of what I said
before they don't want the writers
freaking out so they don't want to send
it to them ahead of time they would
rather be on the phone and allow the
writer to hear the tone of their voice
and you know all of that so they know
this is not that big of a note and this
is a larger note and we don't want you
to freak out about this and blah blah
blah they they'd rather be able to kind
of control that but no matter what when
a writer receives a note they're feeling
negative stuff you know that's just what
it is good critique bad critique
whatever it is we're feeling critiqued
you know what I mean and so if you give
us that time to kind of sit with it on
our own then we can come back and have
more of a conversation so we can get to
where we need to get so I say yeah ask
doesn't mean that you'll get it but
definitely ask
why do screenwriters think that
executives are the enemy because they
are the ones that are given the notes
you know what I mean and you know kind
of like I said any feedback can just be
taken as I'm bad I'm wrong right so I
spend time you know working with
screenwriters for them to understand
that the executives have a job
their job is to give you feedback that
is not a reflection of who you are as an
individual right they have a job to do
which is this is our brand this is your
story and we need those things to be
this so that means I gotta give you the
notes that are going to get it there
also what I have learned even with
working with professional writers is
just because you're in this room as a
professional writer doesn't mean what
you write is perfect you know what I
mean there are going to be notes there
are things that need to be changed you
can look at it as look at all of the
rest of the people who are part of my
brainstorming committee right you're not
on your own we're so used to doing this
by ourselves in our rooms in our you
know in front of our computers that we
think that we're the only people who
know our characters we're the only
people who can you know decide which
which way things are going to go but
really there are so many other people
who are part of this process who can
make your project fantastic so be
welcoming to the rest of the people in
your brain trust you know what I mean
and so but I can understand them looking
at them as the enemy because they are
the ones who are going to come slice and
dice that thing they are the ones who
are going to come and possibly take it
away from you you know give you your
check take it away from you and then go
off and make it what they want to be by
the time it gets on screen that can be
for the better or for the worse so I can
understand how you could put them in
that in that enemy box but if you more
so consider them your Sidekick you know
what I mean like they're the person who
are here to kind of help you if nothing
else help you make your money right even
if the baby doesn't become the thing you
want it to be they are here to help you
get to the end of your contract so that
you can fulfill it and get your check
they are on your team at least they
should be right and you never know what
personality is going to be like and
people have different personalities and
it might not be that easy of a of a
process but at the end of the day they
are here to help you they want you to
win if you don't win they don't win
right so so they really do want you to
win even if it feels like they're always
you know uh the person who's bearing the
bad news